welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and Joker the joaquin phoenix
origin story of the Clown Prince of
Crime ended in a way that will almost
certainly have the film buff on your
trivia team talking for years to come
I'm gonna talk about everything in this
movies ending so spoiler warning if you
have not seen Joker yet though not
saying the movie hasn't stopped most
people from preforming an opinion about
it okay Joker ended with its violent
antihero lead Arthur Fleck with a kind
of mixed victory after a lifetime of
abuse and mental illness finally gets a
shot at his favorite late-night show
we're on live TV he confesses to
murdering three Wall Street Bros
chastised his Gotham Society and he
shoots not himself as various moments
throughout the movie foreshadowed that
he would but twist
he shoots Robert De Niro's Murray
Franklin in bed spraying this live TV
set with food
the mobs of protesting clowns that his
murders inspired freedom from police
custody
and while the rights consumed Thomas and
Martha Wayne recreating the classic
Bruce wayne/batman origin down to the
snap string of pearls Arthur dances in
victory and uses the hood from his mouth
to make his clown makeup smile even
wider but here's where things get weird
well I guess they got weird from the
opening scene but we cut from Arthur's
victory dance
- Arthur cuffed in a mental institution
the psychologist asks him what's so
funny and he just smiles and says you
wouldn't get it then cut to Arthur
stepping down the facility hallway
leaving bloody footprints behind
implying he murdered that psychologist
and then the orderlies chased him around
like scooby-doo but how does this Indian
reframe the entire Joker film as we know
it I'm gonna break down the deeper
meaning of this final scene here we go
Joker's ending explained so there are at
least two ways that you can interpret
the final act of Joker one is a literal
interpretation of events Arthur Fleck
clown suffering from the mental illness
of pathological laughter he commits
murder he one-point believes his father
is Thomas Wayne but then he learns his
mother lied about that and actually
adopted him allowed him to be abused and
what's he lords about this he murders
his mom and during all this he gets
mocked on his favorite late night show
and he gets invited on that show where
he murders a host incites a riot that
kills the Wayne's and ends up
incarcerated you can see that as your
Joker origin story but there's also
enough evidence throughout this film
telling us that we should not
necessarily interpret these events
literally because Arthur Fleck is an
unreliable narrator well he doesn't
exactly narrate to us but all the movies
events
seen through his eyes and and some key
moments those depictions are revealed to
be Fight Club style subjective fantasies
the first example happens very early in
the movie Arthur watches Murray Franklin
show then the camera slyly cuts to the
inside of that studio with Arthur in the
studio audience no flourish she
transition no pushing on Arthur's eyes
no echoey sound effect signaling the
memory it's just blink and we're there
as if we're cutting from scene to scene
Murray notices Arthur's shrill laugh and
he singles him out he complements him
Arthur stands in the crowd and talks
about his life the crowd affectionately
approves of him
Murray even invites him down to the
stage he hugs him he says that he wishes
he had a son like him and of course this
is a fantasy we've linked back to Arthur
watching Murray on TV it's meant to give
us a peek inside Arthur's mind and what
he wants but I would argue that the
version of events with Murray that the
movie proposes as reality doesn't seem
that plausible either Murray by the in
the film comes off as the exact opposite
of this fantasy he's a cruel bully who
plays the video of a clearly ill
struggling comic to mock him on national
television think about it no affable
late-night host in real life would pull
that kind of dick move like Jay Leno was
kind of a dick behind the scenes
Letterman had some awkward moments I
guess in Johnny Carson probably had some
low blows at roasts but on their own
shows where they're trying to come off
as likable and mainstream none of them
would do something like this it would be
career suicide so I would argue that the
[ __ ] that Murray ends up being isn't
any more realistic than a version and
Arthur's dream scenario now the other
evidence of Arthur's unreliability
pertains to the character of Sophie
played by ZZ beats Arthur and Sofia meet
briefly in the elevator they're building
shortly after he follows her to work but
he backs off and she confronts him about
this but he makes her laugh by telling
her he has a gun and from then on the
two former relationship that makes zero
sense
after killing the bros he knocks on her
door still in clown makeup and plants
one on her and she's like yeah the
creepy clown in my building let's let's
do this baby Fae in your room they go on
dates she watches his catastrophic
stand-up routine and enjoys it every
comic knows this you never invite a girl
on a date to watch you do stand-up no
woman in her right mind would do that
and she joins him in his mother's
hospital room but the fact that this
doesn't make sense is by design because
reality kicks in Arthur interser
apartment later in the movie he sits on
her couch she walks in the room and she
screams she says to him your name's
Arthur right you live in this bill
clearly they actually have no
relationship in the fight club style
callback montage returns to their past
moments together to reveal that Arthur
was alone for all of those moments so
along with these obvious inconsistencies
lots of other elements of the story just
don't add up like how is Arthur able to
get so close to the Wayne family estate
put his fingers in Bruce Wayne's mouth
how is this string being able to
overpower through a gate Alfred
Pennyworth a former British military
officer a trained bodyguard badass how
is Arthur able to casually sneak through
a heavily policed protest to a secured
VIP benefit without anyone calling him
out how does a broke unemployed murder
suspect get his hands on a snazzy suit
and such short notice now I guess to get
chalk all this up to well because of the
movie things need to happen stop
questioning but with clear evidence of
foul play
in the logic of this movie it is fair to
question everything now it's also worth
noting that in his early session with
the psychologist Deborah Kane there's a
quick flashback - Arthur's pastime in a
facility we quickly see him pounding his
head against a wall in that flashback he
wears white and there's all white walls
it's actually pretty similar to the
facility he's in at the end of the film
maybe that's the room that he is in the
whole movie and he could also argue that
the final psychologist the one he kills
might have inspired Deborah Kane in his
fantasy Deborah Kane has to stop
treating him because the state cut her
program but in reality that later
psychologists couldn't help him because
Arthur literally cut her if this second
interpretation is true it would be more
in line with the classic understanding
of the Joker character the Joker's
origin has always meant to be left a
mystery he's a force of anarchy without
any defined sympathetic backstory to
make us feel for him like even in the
story most considered closest to a Joker
origin Alan Moore's The Killing Joke
Joker is like Fleck a struggling comic
but it famously ends with the Joker
implying that his past is actually
multiple choice that was the
interpretation Heath Ledger's Joker used
in the dark night with his shifty
narratives of his scars so by ending
with Arthur incarcerated chuckling to
himself and telling us we wouldn't get
the joke in his head this place is this
joker in that same cryptic boat this
sympathetic narrative we've seen it's
really just one of many options in this
multiple choice question of his life and
it's the option that amuses him in this
moment the one that he doesn't expect
people to get and maybe the part of this
story that tickles him the most is in
this fantasy he gets to create the
Batman rather than the Batman creating
the conditions for Joker's exist
Joker gets to destroy Bruce Wayne's life
and be the spark that ignites Gotham
that's his ultimate fantasy so the
choice is left to you the viewer you can
read Joker as a nihilistic revenge tale
or if that feels off to you it's also
okay to just read the movie as a
fleeting fantasy that cracks a smile
from a broken man but hey that's just my
explanation do you think Arthur's life
story was real or all in his imagination
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on instagram and twitter at EI
vas and to help us finish building our
new home please consider becoming a
patron of new rockstars Digital Studios
patrons will get access to exclusive
premium breakdowns and a bunch of other
cool rewards you can also get on the
list of special shout outs like these I
love all these guys just click on the
link in the description below for more
details
thanks for joining me and to think
Arthur flex whole fate could have been
avoided if those Wall Street bros didn't
sing a song time show tomb at a clown on
the subway
[Music]